before we go tonight we want to pass on  a congratulations to someone we love  there's something called the six  Marathon Majors one of our favorite  producers here Alex McCaskill plans to  run all six of them he just completed  his third in London over the weekend  he's already raced in New York and  Berlin but yesterday in London he was  hoping to beat his previous times and he  did by six minutes he finished the race  in three hours and 23 seconds which is  unbelievably fast if you think about it  I mean seems goin faster than eight  minutes a mile for all 26.2 miles the  guy's a complete savage anyway we just  want to congratulate him Alex McCaskill  and a very good guy